i'm going to start with the spear
sisters while y'all come up with this
song because they are taking their feud
next level yep no feud like a family
feud
britney out solo behind the wheel today
and tearing into her sister again on
instagram calling jamie lynn a selfish
little brat who quote shut me out when i
needed you the most late yesterday the
singer's attorney sent jamie lynn a
scathing cease and desist letter
declaring britney will no longer be
bullied it warns jaime lin to stop
talking about brittany during interviews
for her memoir adding brit will not be
exploited for her sister's monetary gain
i think that this was more of a
threat technique
legal expert rachel stockman believes
the cease and desist is a way to shift
focus i think that britney spears was
trying to change the narrative of what
was going on in the media and basically
trying to paint herself as once again a
victim in this brit's attorney is also
going after her dad jamie spears
claiming in a new separate filing that
britney has paid out a staggering 30
million dollars in legal fees for her
conservatorship and on top of that 6
million to jamie the court papers also
claimed that jaime used some of the
money to pitch a tv cooking show called
cooking cruising and chaos with jamie
spears
today brittany doubled down on her
attacks against jamie lynn saying she
was sad after britney's breakup with
justin timberlake i think everybody
thought it was forever brittany wrote
justin's family was all i knew for many
years she goes on to say she felt like
she was ghosted by jamie lynn after the
split quote you and your friends all
dyed your hair like christina aguilera
and you no longer would play with me
anymore adding she was sorry she quote
wasn't strong enough to do what should
have been done slapped you and mama
right across your blank faces
i think honestly the best move at this
point is just stop making this a public
battle
[Music]